Movie trailers are made to entice you to go
to the theater and buy that outrageously large
bucket of popcorn.
Trailers help studios to decide if the film
is going to be a hit or not and that’s why
studios pay attention to the number of views
a trailer gets when it hits the Internet.
We are able to find hidden details that hint
at what the film is about or what will happen
to a favorite character just by watching a
trailer.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of ten Hidden
Details in Popular Movie Trailers That Went
Unnoticed.
Stick around to learn more about the upcoming
Justice League film and don’t forget to
subscribe to Screen Rant for more fun lists.
LOGAN
Weapon X is one of the greatest X-Men out
there and since 2017’s Logan will be Hugh
Jackman’s last outing as the mutant.
We are excited to see how they end his characters
story.
Some items we learned from the Logan trailer
doesn’t give us much hope for a happy ending
though.
Mutants are dying left and right and Wolverine
and Professor X are aging drastically.
We can also see that Wolverine is no longer
healing without the presence of scares, so
what is going on with mutants?
We hope they figure out what is taking out
the Mutants and Logan finds happiness.
GUARDIANS OF THE GALAXY Vol. 2
Before Guardians of the Galaxy was even released
Marvel already announced their plans to make
a sequel.
The writer and director, Peter Gunn vows to
keep as much of the plot of the sequel out
of the trailers as possible.
Still, we can learn a lot from the trailers.
For instance we see a smaller and now immature
Groot but if we look closely at a prison breakout
scene we notice he is wearing a Ravagers outfit
and symbol.
It looks like he teamed up with Yondu Udonta
and the new mix tape is going to kill.
THE FATE OF THE FURIOUS
The newest Fast and Furious film being released
in 2017 is the eighth film and this time the
variation of the name is The Fate of the Furious.
Not only is there a wrecking ball scene, which
we hope isn’t accompanied by a Miley Cyrus
song but joining the cast is the Oscar winning
actress Charlize Theron.
Theron plays bad girl, Cipher and we see from
the trailer that Vin Diesel later uses the
mask behind her on the wall.
How far will Diesel betray his friends in
this newest installment and does he actually
know what he is doing?
If we don’t find out in this film maybe
we’ll find out in Furious 27 scheduled for
release when Diesel is in his eighties.
SPIDER-MAN HOMECOMING
Last time we saw Peter Parker he was taking
down a giant Ant-Man in 2016’s Captain America:
Civil War.
Fans of Spider-Man were excited to see a pair
of eyes that react and a Parker that actually
looks like he’s in high school.
In the trailer for Spider-Man Homecoming we
actually see a few hidden gems about the MCU.
Not only did we see a bad guy in a Hulk mask,
but in Parker’s science class we also see
a photo of Banner.
If you didn’t get enough Stark in the trailer,
Tony’s dad Howard is featured in a mural
in a hallway too.
BLADE RUNNER 2049
Harrison Ford will be reprising his role in
Blade Runner 2049, which is sure to be an
awesome film.
Ryan Gosling joins him this time around and
with the short one-and-a-half-minute trailer
we can pick up a thing or two about the film.
When Gosling walks into a building, which
we can see it is called, “Vintage Building”
by the rug on the floor.
There are also Korean words in the window,
which translates to “Lucky or Fortunate”
in English, and we hope the film is both.
CARS 3
In the second sequel of the Cars franchise,
Cars 3, the team gets back together for more
laughs and racing excitement.
During the newest trailer we see Lightning
McQueen in a dramatic, slow motion crash.
In the beginning of the trailer we see McQueen
in a crash than later on in the trailer we
see him in a crash again.
But there are big differences between the
two, the first one is during the day and the
second is at night.
Looks like the first one is a dream or back
flash sequence because the colors are diluted
and the characters are not defined also.
BEAUTY AND THE BEAST
The upcoming Beauty and the Beast live-action
film is a remake of the 1991 classic animated
film with the same name.
With the original film the Beast was transformed
as an adult into a beast because of his cold-hearted
and selfish ways.
In the animated film he slashes a painting
of himself as an adult but in the trailer
for the upcoming film he slashes one of a
young boy.
Is the Beast transformed as a boy in this
remake and grew into an adult beast?
We’ll find out soon along side Emma Watson.
JUSTICE LEAGUE
Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice teased
us with the Justice League team by introducing
the characters in an email attachment.
One character was Cyborg, who is played by
Ray Fisher and will be in the upcoming Justice
League film.
In the trailer we see we’re going to get
a back flash scene with Victor Stone.
Traditionally he should be in high school
but since he doesn’t look under eighteen
they put him in college.
Check out that lettermen jacket, who knew
Gotham City had a University and why didn’t
I apply for that school?
PIRATES OF THE CARIBBEAN: DEAD MEN TELL NO
TALES
Since the release of 2003’s first Pirates
of the Caribbean film, the world wanted more
films with the eccentric pirate Captain Jack
Sparrow.
Johnny Depps played this Oscar nominated character
in every film and we can’t imagine anyone
else doing it.
In the trailer we are introduced to a character
named Henry that is behind bars.
We can presume this is Orlando Bloom and Kiera
Knightley’s son because Henry is Bloom’s
characters middle name.
Not to mention he looks like their child.
WONDER WOMAN
Ever since 2016’s Batman v Superman: Dawn
of Justice the Internet has been a buzz about
Gal Gadot starring in her own film.
When watching the trailer for 2017’s Wonder
Woman we learned that even though the DC superhero
could take hits from a genetically-engineered
monster she can’t take a bullet.
In numerous shots from the trailer she deflects
bullets in slow motion to protect others from
death but then deflects one aimed at her.
Also was there a reference to Doctor Poison
in the trailer?
There you have it ten hidden details in popular
movie trailers that went unnoticed and don’t
forget to subscribe to Screen Rant for more
fun videos.
Thanks for watching.